hello and welcome to a week 13 edition
of The Bleacher Report fantasy football
show presented by State Farm my name is
Adam Levitan establish the run.com each
and every week joined by Michael Leone
of establish the run.com to run through
starts sits answer your questions hang
out and talk fantasy football for the
next 30 minutes or so Leon how's it
going today it's going pretty well
excited to talk through this late
indeed hope everybody out there had a
great Thanksgiving and were able to eat
a little bit in the fantasy streets
before we get into our sneaky starts and
our bundles today we wait for some
people to get in here take some
questions from chat to get going kpad
says CJ strad or Russ Wilson this week I
mean just on name value on inseason
production on the eye test it's not even
close CJ strad has been shredding all
year CJ strad the favorite right now to
lead the entire NFL in pass yards this
season Russ Wilson has a bit of a clean
matchup this week though Leon what do
you think about this one stad or Russ
Wilson yeah these guys going
head-to-head in a dome matchup I think
they're both pretty good starts
relatively speaking but I'm going to go
with CJ Stout I think he's going to drop
back he's a good lock for more volume
and just more upside for him than there
is for Russ agreed throw Haymakers says
Trey McBride or Dalton Schultz well
buddy we have breaking news for you here
uh throw Haymakers we are projecting D
Schultz to miss this game due to injury
uh not good on Dalton Schultz Trey
McBride is banged up also with a groin
thing but I think it sounds like Trey
McBride's goingon to be able to play I
probably would have said McBride anyways
over Stroud maybe not but uh but yeah it
looks like that decision will be Made
For You Dalton the goat says courand
Sutton Jonathan Mingo or Romeo dos this
week we saw Mingo get going a little bit
last week I've been impressed with the
chemistry between Russ and Sutton though
lately any thoughts on that one
Leone yeah I think Sutton's just in a
higher tier than these guys uh we've
seen Russ's TD rate be pretty good he
can get the ball down field like I said
not as much volume as CJ st's going to
have but uh su's emerged as his go-to
Target there so I'm I'm going with Su in
that group and I think it's a pretty
easy decision for me yep agreed ktown
says Devon Smith or Jamar Chase oh we
have the humble brags coming in Leon
Devon Smith or or Jamar chase you got
the sick team here obviously with Joe
burrow I would never be sitting Jamar
Chase I can understand people now who
want to have questions because Jake
Browning is not Jamar Chase I was
encouraged though with the way way they
called the game I mean they did not go
into some shell and say we're just going
to run it because we don't have Joe
burrow they let Jake Brown and get out
there and throw it so what do you think
about this one Leone Devonte Smith in
his tough match up here or Jamar Chase
with Jake brownie yeah I'm with you that
I was encouraged by the play calling
they were way more pass heavy than I
thought with all that said I still am
going to lean towards the better
quarterback play and say Devonte Smith
who we have projected about a point
higher right now also looking at Jamar
Chase's game log don't want to R too
much into it but his Target shares the
last four weeks 18% 15% 23% 23% those
are pretty low numbers for him uh I
don't really know if that's just noise
small sample or if it has to do with
brownie not able to get him the ball as
much and people are able to key in on
Chase a bit more with Barrow not back
there but that's a little bit of a
concern in addition to the quarterback
play for
me all right we'll come back to some
more questions from chat in a little bit
here do you want want to get to the
featured segment of this week's show
which is sneaky starts we tried to find
some guys who were kind of on the border
of being starts or sits for a lot of
people came up with six guys who we
think will perform well this week and
we'll start with our first one in the
game tonight Dallas against Seattle
first one is Brandon Cooks and I think
what we've seen is Michael Gallup
recede we've seen Tony Pard role reced
and we've seen Dallas be among the most
throw heavy teams in the league for the
last five weeks and also rely more on
Brandon Cooks to do so and I'm worried
about this Seattle Team it feels like
they're just completely falling apart in
front of our eyes so I think a pretty
good spot here for Brandon Cooks for
people who are on the fence about
starting him Leon any thoughts on Cooks
then we can go to our second sneaky
start yeah he's had route share of
around 80% in three of the last four
games as you said gp's role is receding
him and Tolbert are kind of splitting as
the wide receiver three there and Cooks
has emerged as the clear wide receiver
to behind CD lamb so yeah in conjunction
with the increased pass rate for Dallas
things are looking really really strong
for him going to the number two guy on
our list though you've got DeAndre
Hopkins in a pretty good matchup against
the Colts I think you're going to see
Tennessee throw more than they have the
last couple weeks two weeks ago they
just got dominated in play Volume last
week they played from a hat against a
bad Carolina team now you've got them as
underdogs against a Colts team that runs
really uptempo so I think you're going
to see things swing back around in terms
of the pass volume for Tennessee and
we've just seen this ceiling uncapped a
little bit with the switch from Tanana
Hill to lvis opening up some more
touchdowns for Hopkins some more down
the field stuff so excited for him this
week yeah my thing is I want to play
play perimeter wide receivers against
the Colts they have been getting torched
all year have the Colts they play so
fast we saw Mike Evans did uh last week
to the Colts it's DeAndre Hopkins turn
this week all right let's get back to
some of the chats that's why we're here
Leon to help the good our good friends
in chat we'll start with Hernandez he
says Rashid rice Josh DS or Garrett
Wilson in standard man I don't Hernandez
might be the first person that I've seen
or spoken to who still plays in a
standard League by standard he means you
don't get any points for a reception you
only get points for yards gained or
touchdowns I think from a touchdown
perspective the guy most likely to score
a touchdown on this list to me is going
to be Rashid rice just because he's
affiliated with Patrick Mahomes here
against the Packers but yeah any
thoughts on this one
Leone yeah if it wasn't standard I'd
just say to take the volume from Garrett
Wilson but it is pretty empty volume and
in a standard League that brings him
down honestly we have like all three
guys projected within a point of one
another um I think I'd go Rashi rice too
it seems like the role is growing for
him we've said that a couple of times
this year but it seems like it might be
a bit stickier this time and like you
said for standard League touchdown
upside is the best for him of the three
due to the team total I'm playing with
Mahomes yeah yeah Hernandez you should
tell your commissioner that your boycott
in the league unless they move to at
least a half uh PPR setting let's go to
Biggie OTB he says Should I stick with
Jackson Smith in jiga at Flex or take a
chance with t Higgins in PPR the report
today out of Cincinnati was that t
Higgins said he's going to play I we've
seen this story before with t Higgins
Leone where he says he's healthy he says
he's fine he goes out there and he's
either a decoy or he's not involved D or
he or he aggravates or he only plays a
few of the snaps like he has a history
of doing this he's also an impending
free agent like he doesn't need to go
out there as an impending free agent
with Jake Browning and hurt his
hamstring again or put bad tape out
there so I have bad vibes about him that
said I don't feel great about jsn here
tonight either against the Cowboys I
might just take the healthy guy though
uh what do you think about this one jsn
or t Higgins I think I'd take the
healthy guy I mean if burrow was that
quarterback it'd be a different story
you'd want to risk the Higgins upside
but with burrow out you know the wide
receiver to there is not super valuable
and we've seen at least you know from a
positive standpoint for jsn there hasn't
been a ton positive this year but they
are starting to run like three wide
receiver sets a lot more consistently he
had an 86% route share last week that
was with meta and Lockett running their
normal routes too seen less of the
second tight end in there like Kobe
Parkinson will dley their routes are
down so that's a good thing for Seattle
team that probably going to be forced to
throw a good bit this week even if it is
somewhat empty
volume RB frabel has a humble brag
Brandon iuk or Michael Pitman in full
PPR I mean these are two awesome plays
this week it would be hard for me to sit
Brandon auk against this Eagle secondary
everybody's game plan against the Eagles
is throw the football because they're
pretty good against the run but they're
awful I mean their Corners are really
really struggling and slow out there I I
don't want to sit Pitman I definitely
don't want to sit Pitman but I don't
know if I could sit auk in this setup
either against the Eagles any thoughts
on this one
Leone I'd probably go iuk just because
of how efficient the San Francisco
offense has been and exactly what you
said the way to attack Philly is through
the air they have one of the highest
pass right over expectations against and
if San Francisco's push I think there's
like just a really huge ceiling for auk
because of how good he's been he just
doesn't get a ton of volume because they
generally aren't in the scripts for that
5dg says is Sam Howell a good
replacement for Lamar Jackson on by week
so I think you know what you get from
Sam Howell you get a guy who literally
is going to drop Back 40 times every
game which is insane to say but that is
what the commanders have been doing all
year Eric bemy came from Kansas City and
said we're going to treat Sam Howell on
this offense like we have Patrick
Mahomes we're going to drop Back 40
times every game and we're throw it to
eight nine 10 different guys every game
as well it would be hard to say if Sam
hell is your best choice without knowing
what else is out there but against the
Dolphins who can be very efficient on
offense themselves I think 40 dropbacks
is pretty likely any thoughts on
Howell's spot here against the Dolphins
Leone well I'm in some leagues where
I've got Lamar Jackson on by and I've
had to pick up bayy zappy so uh you know
Sam Hall sounds pretty great to me from
that perspective like you're going to
get a dude who's going to drop back a
ton and I think that's sort of all you
can ask and he's been like pretty decent
too as well a touch of rushan upside so
yeah I think H's a fine pickup we've
also got Montoya beats three asking
Jerome Ford or Zack chanet in PPR this
week um man that's might it might be Joe
flacko it might be Joe flacko starting
for The Browns by the
way and I'm going to go with chanet
who's just absolutely dominated the
running back Touches for Seattle since
Kenneth Walker went out I know it's like
not an ideal spot for a running back
being big dogs against this really good
Dallas defense but the guaranteed
touches are so so strong for Charan and
he can do it in the pass game too so you
can get you know some some checkdowns
and stuff late if they're playing from
behind all right appreciate the
questions from chat let's get back to
our sneaky starts from this week so
someone that was likely able to be
picked up off waivers this week is my
old friend from Penn State Pat friou now
Fruth broke out in a big way last week
against the Bengals and I think part of
that at least was matchup driven Bengals
been getting torched by everyone
certainly by tight ends this week he has
another amazing matchup against the
Cardinals and the big thing of course is
Matt Cannon is gone which I don't think
it makes that big a difference but where
it did make a difference what you can
see is they were more focused on running
first read rfts in the middle of the
field and that is where Pat fouth wins
obviously he always has a really good
bet for a touchdown here and like if
there was ever a spot for Kenny picket
to actually have a good game and by the
way Kenny picket has had like one good
fantasy game in his entire career but if
there was ever a spot for Kenny picket
to have a good fantasy game it would be
this home against the Cardinals so if
you picked up Pat fouth I think you got
to start him this week here Leon I don't
want to go overboard though on a guy who
we've seen airball a ton this
year yeah I mean tight ends just guys
are going to airball but you're right it
is good opportunity to bet on a roll
increase we saw last week carrying over
and softened by the fact that you're
facing an Arizona defense that is 31st
in past dvoa according to
ftn our fourth sneaky start of this week
is a defense the Jacksonville DST so
we're getting creative with this one and
part of the reason we like this defense
Adam is part of the reason we weren't
like totally out on Jamar Chase it's
that Cincinnati is actually going to
throw with Jake Browning but that's what
you want as an opposing defense drop
backs or opportunities for sacks
turnovers that's where defenses really
make their day so to get a team that's
willing to throw as eight and a half
Point dogs probably not going to score a
lot you know that that that's all you
can ask for yeah I think for people who
are trying to optimize their teams for
the playoffs we have some
uh content on the site about stashes and
what kind of defenses you should be
stashing but there are so many bad
quarterbacks this year on every team I
feel like every week I can go to the
waiver wire and find a really good
defense to pick up I mean Tommy deito
Jake Browning I mean these are guys that
you are getting Dro back a ton and you
can get so many defensive points with so
yeah just be on top of that uh all right
a few chat questions here Ty Law 3 I
wonder if that's Ty Lawson I was always
a big Ty Lawson fan going back to North
Carolina days anyways Ty Lawson 3 Says Z
Jones or Christian Watson we saw
Christian Watson finally break out last
week meanwhile Z Jones is kind of the
third wide receiver who's been buried I
think that's a pretty easy one to go
back to Christian Watson there D Kramer
88 says Lions defense or bucks defense
this week bucks are home against Bryce
young certainly a good spot lions are on
the road against Derek
Carr I think bucks probably Derek Carr
is so conservative that a lot lot of
times he doesn't make a ton of mistakes
I know he's made a ton of mistakes
especially in the Red Zone this year but
I think I would lean bucks there against
Bryce young but it's close what do you
think
Leon yeah I think it's the Bucks defense
we've also seen the Detroit defense
struggle a decent bit this last stretch
of games I mean everybody saw it on
Thanksgiving with them making Jordan
love
look like Joe Montana out there and uh
that's sort of reflected in the Vegas
lines where New Orleans expected to
score 21 points is their median
expectation in this game for Carolina
their median expectation is just 16
points that's a pretty huge difference
so I think you know based on probably
gonna let up less points for Tampa Bay
and also I think you get a little bit
more pick six Equity like that type of
big mistake from Bryce young we've
already seen it from him a few times
this year
Mr J sneaky says Jaylen Wadd or Nico
Collins um Jaylen waddle is not going to
find a better matchup than this one all
year we already talked about how the
commanders play it leads to a ton of
opportunities for the other team a ton
of plays in the game overall and man
they traded Chase young they traded
montz sweat they had to bench their
first round cornerback I mean this is
the worst defense you can make a case in
the entire league so I'd be hard rest to
sit Wadd here but one thing I will say
Leon is that when Tyreek Hill has been
on the field it's not been great for
Jaylen Wadd and Target share it really
hasn't When J Tyreek Hill has like
missed like a series or two and Jaylen
wad goes nuts but when Tyreek is out
there so much is for him so I can make
case for Nico I think I'd go Wadd but I
can make case for Nico any thoughts here
yeah it's super close I've just got to
go with like like I think the average
outcome for these two players is pretty
pretty similar but I think wad has a
chance to just break like two massive
plays against this Washington defense
I'd really be kicking myself if I didn't
start him so I'm gonna go with waddle
but nothing like super scientific there
I just feel like the really high-end
ceiling for him is just monstrous in
this match up against
Washington all right now it's time for
everybody's favorite portion of the
program which is of course the
bundles we're going to jump into our
fantasy bundles now presented by our
friends at State Farm we're build we're
bundling your home and auto insurance is
just another way to save with the
personal price plan at State Farm all
right for anyone who is new bundles of
course is
teammates uh that we think work well on
a given week if you're playing DFS if
you're playing DFS tournaments that's
kind of the specialty and what we do at
establish the run and so what you're
going want to be doing in these
tournaments is typically stacking a
quarterback with a pass catcher if your
quarterback has an outsize game there's
a pretty good chance that one of his
pass catchers at least will have an
outsize game as well number one is the
no-brainer two it took of aloa and
Tyreek Hill this week just talked about
this Commander's secondary and the way
that they play Tyreek is wants to get
2,000 yards Tyreek wants to get his name
into the MVP conversation I think him
and Christian mcaffry are the overruling
favorites for offensive player of the
year I don't think they mind running up
the score on anyone and so Tua to Tyreek
is an absolute no-brainer stack this
week Leon you can go ahead with our
second bundle of the week no I mean nice
to you to take two to Tyreek and leave
me with Russell Wilson so that's that's
fantastic but uh we've been talking
positively about this match up for
Russell Wilson and courland suon against
Houston a game that like could be sneaky
fast like these are two teams that both
the quarterbacks are really high up
there in terms of yards per completion
which can lead to some quicker drives
and some back and forth action so I
think it's a fun dome game to attack
this week and with uh Houston in
particular their run defense is 10th
into dvoa pass defense is 26 so some
reason to think that Denver might pass a
little bit more than they have recently
or before forced to do
so third bundle of the week is going to
be Aker Mayfield to Mr Mike Evans I mean
I can't believe what Mike Evans is doing
age 30 with Baker Mayfield dude
is balling I mean having one of the best
seasons out of any wide receiver in the
NFL now he gets the matchup that
everybody's been feasting on which is
home against the Panthers I guess what
surprised me most about Mike Evans is
how much he's separated from Chris
Godwin I thought that they would be
relatively even here but Mike M Evans
has just completely crushed him Baker to
Mike Evans really good bet I think for a
touchdown this week Leone go ahead with
the fourth bundle yeah I'll go to the
Trevor Lawrence to Evan Ingram I know
Ingram hasn't scored a touchdown yet
this season I'm very well aware of it as
I was watching him wide open in the end
zone last week and Lawrence sail the
ball over his head but starting to see
some better usage for him some Endzone
looks last week some down the field
looks for him and now he gets that
matchup against Cincinnati that we were
talking about with Pat Fri M that just
took advantage of that in a big way
they've been getting shredded by tight
ends in the establish the Run DVP tool
that's trying to be a bit more
predictive and accounting for how teams
usually use their players we have
Cincinnati as the sixth most favorable
matchup for opposing tight
ends Fifth and final State Farm bundle
of the week is Patrick Mahomes to Rashi
rice
now I think Rashid rice should be
playing 100% of the snaps I know that
Chiefs aren't going to do that Rashid
rice has never run more than 68% of the
routes in a game this season it seems
like they have no interest in getting
him up higher than that but we got the
reports last week that Chiefs have been
focusing as they've been struggling on
offense focusing on putting their best
players in the best positions that's
Rashi rice they've been focusing on
getting their young wide receivers
playing faster that's Rashi rice and you
see it pay off in the game last week at
this point the best way for the Chiefs I
think to move the football is obviously
still use Kelce but you got to use Rashi
rice a ton more and I think the Chiefs
are starting to realize that so I'll go
Patrick Mahomes to Rashi rice for the
fifth and final
bundle all right back to some chats from
our fans out there are adoring fans a
bevy says back in and cidi should be a
bundle this week man Dak and cidi are a
bundle every week for sure we do have CD
lamb we actually showed some value on CD
lamb to lead the game in receiving yards
tonight and so yes we certainly like Dak
to cidd tonight gamri TV says Zack Moss
or DeAndre Swift so if you were carrying
Zach Moss or if you were able to add
Zach Moss you got an awesome pickup I
think he could play 90% or more of the
snaps here and he's proven to be a
pretty effective guy I hate sitting
DeAndre Swift just a really good player
and a really good offense but I think I
might even go Moss here Leone what do
you think about this
one yeah I would go Moss we actually
have him with an outrageous projection I
feel like I need to double check it but
we do have him like pretty clear of
DeAndre Swift to start and to your point
about 90% snaps the three weeks that
Moss played earlier this year without JT
he played 98 % 76% and 83% of the snaps
in JT's return game where he was a bit
more limited Moss still played 80% of
the snaps so yeah it's it's a good
matchup too against Tennessee already
noted how Indy's gonna play uptempo he's
you know if you've got him you're
basically starting him in almost every
format from Cole Mahoney says tank Dell
or Adam Thelen so tank Dell is on the
injury report this week sounds like he's
going to play and I assume he's going to
be fine but he's a little bit banged up
Adam Thelen at his age I just assume is
always banged up at this point in this
season think certainly is the big play
guy Adam thielen I think in is in a
pretty good bounceback spot against the
Bucks to catch a bunch of balls but man
it is really hard to sit tank Dell right
now by the way if you're just looking at
the box score from last week it's not as
good as it should be for tankal he had a
62 yard catch called back by an illegal
shift which was week uh did tank Dell so
yeah I think it's tank Dell for me what
do you think Leon Dell or
Thelen yeah I gotta go tank Dell I just
think the upside is too huge you've got
much better quarterback play you've got
a player that can make a big play down
the field which Adam Thelen really can't
do the targets per out run yards per
rout run the route share everything for
Dell is trending up and looks really
strong I will say we do have Adam Thelen
as our fifth sneaky start of the week so
if you have a worse option than tank D I
do think going to Adam th makes some
sense it's a good matchup against Tampa
Bay teams routinely they're throwing
more frequently against Tampa Bay then
they will a normal team Tampa Bay has a
pass rate overe expectation against them
of plus 4% that's one of the highest in
the league so that's just because of the
makeup of their defense and I think we
could see Carolina exploit that there's
also maybe some hidden upside in the
Carolina offense with the coaching
change and just how bad things were
under Frank Reich and maybe you just get
that one weak momentum bump with the
switch there for Carolina yeah I think
it's a really nice bounceback spot for
Adam thielen and agree you know I prefer
tank Dell but certainly a good spot for
Adam thielen Sixth and final sneaky
start of the week is one that's off the
board but man Michael Thomas is out
Rasheed Shahed is almost certainly going
to be out Chris Salve is in a time
crunch to get cleared from concussion
protocol they're down to Total dust at
pass catcher I think Joan Johnson's
going to play a ton but you have to get
T Tamm Hill involved if you're the
Saints this week I mean absolutely have
to home game against the Lions I think
it would be irresponsible not to get
tesm Hill six to 10 touches in this game
if you're coaching the Saints and maybe
more and that means taking direct snaps
that means catching the ball that means
doing all kinds of tesm Hill things
especially around the goal line so yeah
it's hard to get there on projection
with tesm Hill because a lot of it is
just outlier stuff a lot of it is
touchdown dependent stuff but this week
I feel like we can start to give him a
reasonable Target share and Carries as
well so
sixth start of the week Mr
tesm
Hill just to recap our favorite sneaky
starts of the week Brandon Cooks of the
Cowboys DeAndre Hopkins in a clean match
up for the Titans Pat Fruth
postm Canada era more over the- middle
stuff Jacksonville Jaguars defense
against Jake Browning Adam
thielen the Elder Statesman in a very
good matchup against the Bucks and taes
Hill as part of a very banged up skill
position unit for the
Saints All right we have about five more
minutes here we'll get to as many
questions as we can btb says Kareem hunt
or Damen Pierce in standard League
another standard League Leone Kem hunt
or Damen Pierce so what we've seen from
Damen Pierce is that he's been iced he's
been iced by Devin single ter yeah the
carries were somewhat close last week
but Deon single ter played so many more
snaps Kem hunt on the other hand similar
situation he's behind Drome Ford but I
think his usage is a little bit better
quarterback play though is way better
for Pierce what do you think about this
one Leone I will go creem hunt here I
just think the solidified goal line role
and how committed to the Run Cleveland
should be with flacko behind the helm
you know tilts tilts the The Ledger that
way CLE says Jaden Reed or George
Pickins um George Pickins didn't really
see a role change with Matt Canan agon
jayen re continues I think to impress on
a weekly
basis I think it would probably still be
Pickins for me though because this
matchup for George pi
against Arizona is like as good as it
gets for his skill set what do you think
there yeah I agree pickings for me with
the upside against how bad this Arizona
defense is Wolf 28 asks Jerome Ford or
na Harris so more Pittsburgh questions
more Cleveland backfield questions I
think I'll lean the way of Jerome Ford
here stick with the Cleveland backfield
but um you know we did see Pittsburgh's
offense break out in a huge way last
week and pretty much everyone benefited
from that n got a ton of volume even
splitting with Jaylen Warren I just
think um you know Ford's involvement in
the past game could be better than n's
this week and that's why I like him yeah
I'll go for a rare disagreement I think
I'll go nii here just for the Arizona
matchup I you know I think I have to I
just wanted to make you pick naagi in
something Anthony says could Rico Dow be
considered a sneaky start this week so
we haven't seen them take that much
usage off Tony Pard we've seen them take
a little bit off I know Rico D has
gotten a couple screens around the goal
line which have happened to go for
touchdowns I'm not sure that that was
purposeful rather than just giving Tony
Pard a break but yeah I mean I think you
can get six or seven touches out of Rico
Dow in a pretty good spot here tonight
I'd be trying to start someone else with
more upside I think but if you had to I
think it's
okay bran five says Matthew Stafford or
Jordan love um Jordan love has a very
difficult matchup this Chiefs defense
and secondary has been awesome of course
Brown's defense and secondary has been
awesome all year as well any take on
this one Leon Stafford or Jordan love
straight
up I think I lean love I think there's a
touch Mark upside with Stafford I'm
worried that it's a tough matchup and
they might not need to throw so like the
combination of low pass pass volume with
maybe not that great of pass efficiency
to begin with kind of stinks where his
love at least you know you should get
him in a situation where he has to drop
back more
frequently last question we're going to
do today Johnny
Utah uh I believe that's a shout out to
one of my favorite movies of all time
Point Break but anyways uh says DeAndre
Hopkins George Pickins or Drome Ford in
the flex full PPR already talked about
how I really like this spot for DeAndre
Hopkins I'd go with him
but what do you think
Leon I'm with you DeAndre Hopkins there
I mean it's a little bit close but full
PPR scoring the wide receiver generally
just has a better floor ceiling
combination to begin with and we like
the spot for
Hopkins all right that is going to do it
for the week 13 bleach report fantasy
football show presented by State Farm if
you're serious about fantasy football or
want to get serious about fantasy
football be sure you're on Twitter
that's where all the best fantasy
football information is be sure you're
following me at Adam Lan Leone two hats
one Mike I'm sure you're already
following bleach report and who doesn't
want to follow their favorite insurance
provider on Twitter be sure you're
following State Farm on Twitter as well
four Leone for all people behind the
scenes at Bleacher Report I am indeed
Adam good luck
everybody